[inaudible] joining me today is the
president of the Hertzel Institute in
Jerusalem,
the Director of the John Templeton
Foundation project in Jewish Philosophical
Theology, and the author of several books,
including the virtue of nationalism.
Your arm has xone. Welcome to the
Rubin report. Thanks for having me.
It's great to be here.
I am glad to have you here because as
I said to you in the green room just a
moment ago,
you're one of about 12 people that I
see on Twitter that doesn't completely
enrage me. You actually make a little
bit of sense on that Twitter machine.
That's the highest compliment.
I can positively pay any of that,
that that's a pretty serious compliment.
And I don't know how many
people would agree with you,
but I'm glad finally to meet with
that background. That's that.
That's wonderful. Thank you. Yeah. So,
okay. So before we get into the book,
and it's called the virtue of nationalism,
and just even just saying
the word nationalism sort
of sets bells off for a lot
of people. So we're gonna,
we're going kind of, uh,
quantify and qualify what
that word actually means.
Uh, you were born in Israel,
you live in Jerusalem. Now. Tell me a
little bit about your background. Well,
in between the being born in Israel and
living in Jerusalem, I actually, you can,
you can hear the, my Irish
American education not to
fully Israeli accent. Yeah.
So I, I grew up in, uh, in
Princeton, New Jersey and, uh,
went to school there. I
met my wife there, uh, uh,
did a doctorate at Rutgers and you're
buying in political theory and um,
and then, uh, Julian,
I moved to Israel. We,
uh, I worked for a while for net
to now for a few years, uh, quite,
quite awhile ago already.
Uh, and then set up a, uh,
a conservative think tank
called the Shalom Center,
which did about 20 years of of work trying
to figure out what Israeli and Jewish
conservatism would, would be
like. We have nine kids and,
uh, which is probably the, the,
the, the biggest achievement.
And I've been kind of pulled back.
You've,
you've noticed in the last few years
pulled back into American and European,
uh, issues, because, you know, for,
for most of my life I felt like Israel
was the front lines and that, you know,
that that's where I was really needed.
And these days,
like for the first time in my
life, I feel that, you know,
America and Europe are actually kind
of in worse shape than Israel is.
So what do you mean by that?
How was Israel at the front lines where
that's now shifted is really used to be
a, uh, I mean, it still is to
an extent a, a, a strong and uh,
I'm sorry, as a small and
struggling country, um,
in, in a sense like the,
the edge between, uh, the,
the order of the Western world
and kind of kind of, uh, uh, uh,
chaotic bedlam and ended a little, uh, uh,
needed a lot of help in order
to strengthen itself. Uh,
America looked fine for
most of that time. And, uh,
today I think the situations almost
flipped where Israel is the strongest that
it's ever been. And in a lot of ways,
uh, as, as, as defeated many of its,
uh, of the problems the dog
did in the last generation. Um,
and, uh, and America's fraying and,
and the UK is fraying. And, you know,
I don't have to tell you, I mean,
it's not like, uh, Israel is, is, is
going to do well if, if, you know,
the entire west kind of disintegrates.
So,
um, so I've spent the last
few years, uh, and that,
that's how we know each other
through, through, through,
through Twitter and, and,
uh, uh, writings that are
directed and trying to, uh,
to help American,
the UK and other,
other western countries with the issues
that I think are facing them now.
So we're going to spend most of the
interview, obviously talking about issues,
but nine kids living in Jerusalem,
what's living in Jerusalem? Like,
I feel like it's probably,
maybe not, probably, maybe,
maybe exactly the most misunderstood
place on planet earth for good reason.
Oh, Gosh. I mean it's, it's, uh, in,
in some ways it's just a
dream, you know, I mean, I, I,
I walk on Friday night with
my, uh, uh, we have, uh, uh,
twin twin 10 year olds,
and I walk with them to synagogue.
We walked down the hill to synagogue and,
uh, and you can see the whole city from,
from where we are, cause it's
kind of on a hill. And, um,
and uh, you know, for,
for, for a Jew it's some,
it's really kind of a miracle that after
a couple of thousand years in which my
ancestors were,
were praying,
please God bring us back so that one
day we'll be able to, you know, to,
to see the Jews returned to Jerusalem
and we actually get to see it.
So it's, it's incredibly
moving and it never loses its,
it's magic. But, um, you know, on
the other hand, it's also, you know,
it's also a very real place in, in,
in, in a very real political location.
And, um, uh, today everything
is basically, you know,
quiet and peaceful and Jerusalem pretty
much all the time. But, um, you know,
just if you go, go, go back
just to the mid two thousands,
uh,
we had a period where there were literally
bombs going off in the cafes and the
buses of, of the city every
day. And, uh, and when, uh,
Israel invaded, uh, Bethlehem, um,
to put in an end to
this, my, my wife and I,
then we were living on the southern
part of the city. And, um, you know,
we walked hand in hand up to a hill
from which we could see the, the, uh,
Israeli armor entering the city and the,
the tanks shooting.
And W I mean,
it's like what you see on television,
except we just sat there and watched
it with it, with our own eyes. Um,
so, uh, you know,
we had six months at that time in which
we had helicopter helicopters patrolling
over our house every night. And,
uh, and so it's both things.
It's both. Um, the, it, it,
it's both the front lines
of civilization and, uh,
and you can feel the fragility of,
you know, what we've built. We can,
you can feel that it's fragile.
And,
and know that nothing is certain
about what's going to happen next.
On the one hand, on the other hand,
it, you know, you on a daily basis,
you're connecting to a history of
thousands of years and to, uh, you know,
biblical hopes and aspirations
that you know, that for, for,
for people in, in America, it's mostly
school books, but for, you know,
the things that you learned as a kid in,
in,
in school or in Sunday
school or someplace, but, uh,
or you hear from your grandparents. But
here we're really doing it will really,
uh, recreating, uh, uh, a Jewish
country after thousands of years. So,
uh, it's, it's the highest and the lows
and, and it's an extraordinary life.
Do you think in a weird way
that the threat of bombings
or terrorism or whatever
else is going on or the general seemingly
existential threat because it's such a
small country actually helps the
ingenuity that comes at Israel?
Because I remember I was there a few
years ago during the stabbing sprees and I
went right into the old city of Jerusalem
and you know, my mom was texting me,
you know, you, you don't have to go there.
And I just went right in and I remembered
there was a certain tension, you know,
it was kind of looking around,
but I went into the Arab quarter and I
walked through the gate and somebody had
just been stabbed there the day
before and I thought, you just,
you just have to keep going.
If people can live like this,
I can certainly do it for one day of my
life, for a couple of hours in my life.
Yeah. I, I, first of all, I'm,
I'm real pleased that you did that. You
know, a lot of people just get scared and,
and, and, and, you know, seeing
something, seeing something on television,
sing some violence and then deciding
you're going to live your life.
You're going to decide where you're going
to go and what you're going to do and
what you're going to save because you
saw something on TV and got scared. I,
I mean, I understand it, but, but I
don't think it's the best way to live.
And,
um,
well you can also see that these
people live on top of each other.
These quarters are right
on top of each other.
And I had CANASTA and the Arab quarter
and I had falafel in the Jewish quarter
and everyone's existing and not killing
each other. I mean, that's the truth.
Truth,
right? They, uh, they do.
Uh, but our, you know,
our future depends on, on, you
know, countless little act of,
of, you know, of bravery like that.
Like, I'm not going to be deterred.
I'm going to go eat,
I'm going to go eat that fell off.
I'm going to lead a normal life here.
That's what builds the normal life is
people like you saying that. So, uh,
it's, uh, there really is a, uh,
a daily effort which, um, uh,
which is built on countless small
acts of, uh, uh, of bravery.
And, uh, um, there,
there's a ton mutek a famous telemetric
saying how it's in the can that be slim
that, uh, the land is only, um, one, uh,
through hardship. And these are little
tiny hardships that, you know, some, some,
some something scared you,
something feels field feels uncomfortable,
but you're going to do the
right thing anyway. It's good.
It's good to live that way.
It's good to live, not afraid.
Well said. All right, so let's talk
about nationalism because as I said,
if you just say the word nationalism
or if you say I'm a national list or
anything like that,
the connotations or the implications
are that you're somehow racist.
You're Zena phobic, all of
these things. So first off,
can you just define at least in
your view what nationalism is?
Sure. Um, I, I actually, I, I grew
up in a nationalist house, you know,
meaning like, like many Israelis
doing, it's not just Israelis, um,
people in India, people in
Ireland. There's a lot of
countries in the world where,
where people still remember that a
national movement is, uh, is, uh,
a struggle against empire.
And so it's a struggle for freedom
and it still has good connotations.
Um, so in, in those kinds of
traditions, uh, which I draw on in, in,
in my book, nationalism is
understood to be a, uh, uh,
a principled stand point that
sees the world is governed best,
uh, when it consists of
many independent nations.
So each nation will have its own laws,
its own traditions, it's own, uh,
language and religious,
uh,
customs and will live
independently without being
forced to live a certain way,
uh, by, by, by, by other nations.
Mine, right? And this is,
this is basically how we've viewed the
world for the last hundred years or so,
right?
I mean,
most relatively sane people that there
are countries and they have borders,
they're different units. They can
negotiate together, right? But, but, but,
but it's not, uh, um,
it's this way of viewing the world is
about three or 400 years old in its
current version. In the book, I
actually argued that, uh, that,
that this is a biblical ideal, right? You,
you don't find the Greeks or the Romans,
uh,
painting a picture of a
world of independent nations
that that vision of a world
of independent nations is a, is
something that inherits a, I'm sorry,
that that enters our
inheritance, uh, from, uh,
from Hebrew Bible. And then it
appears throughout, you know,
throughout Western history
in various forms in, uh, in,
in various parts of
Christian Christian history.
So in its current form that the feeling
of a just world of free world is one of
competition among independent
peoples. Um, it, it's about,
depending on how you count, it's about
three or 400 years old. The first,
the first country in Europe to, to, um,
to explicitly declare
independence is, uh, is, uh,
England and 1534, um, uh,
Henry and read the eighth says,
we're not even formally going to be
part of the holy Roman empire anymore.
We're just, we're just independent.
We're doing our own thing. And that,
that model was picked up by,
uh, by the Dutch, by the Scots,
by the Swiss, by the French,
by various others. And, uh,
and then becomes kind of the basis for
a, uh, an ordering of the world where,
where this became more
and more the intuition.
Of course there were plenty of plenty
of empires during those times in lots of
injustice. And, and I, I don't want to
turn it into like some kind of, you know,
utopia or something wasn't,
but slowly the,
the idea that there's something good
about allowing nations to, to, to,
to go their own way and to be free,
that that did become the common,
a common sense view and still was
up until up until World War II.
I think it was really only
in the 1960s that, um,
that academics and intellectuals
really turned against,
against this idea and began arguing
that nationalism is just, you know,
is just an evil. Right. So
what shifted then in the 1960s?
Because when you talk about nations with
borders that can decide what they do
within their borders and that people
can have a nationalism that they can be
proud of that is in xenophobic
or racist or the resident,
I think that makes sense to most people.
Right. I, it is, you said common sense,
it strikes me as common sense.
So what happened in the 60s was that sort
of a latent period after World War II,
that these ideas bubble
up through academia. It's,
it's all about the trauma of World
War One and World War II. It,
it's all about that. And um, the, uh,
beginning immediately after
World War II, um, there were, uh,
Marxists and there were liberals who
said, ah, look, Hitler's a nationalist.
And it's true that Hitler called
himself a nationalist. I mean, it gets,
are called himself a nationalist,
but he's actually an imperialist
because from the very beginning,
his goal was not for Germany to,
you know, to, to be independent.
His goal was for Germany
to become, as he said, uh,
Lord of the Earth,
mistress of the globe.
So Hitler's not, not, you know,
our traditional idea of a national piece,
understanding of rationalism right
there. Right. Because if he had been, uh,
if just if you had been a nationalist by
the strict definition that he wouldn't
have wanted to do anything
outside. Right. So,
so he would have been
terrible for Germany,
but not necessarily a s, uh, starting,
uh, world war with France and England
and Russia and everybody else.
It would have been terrible
for Germany anyway, but,
but you can't call him a nationalist.
According to my tradition,
if his dreams aspiration is not the
freedom of his people, his dream,
you know, among other peoples,
his aspiration is to, is
to rule the globe. Right?
Was expanding. Okay. So, uh, so
imperialism versus nationalism,
that's for people who are nationalists
instead of critics of national for people,
our nationals. That's the big
divide. Um, is, are you looking,
are you willing to give the respect of
self determination to many nations like
your own, um, or, or are, are, are,
are you really just looking to conquer
the world? So after World War II, um,
various, uh, uh,
anti nationalist theories that hadn't
succeeded in getting traction up until
then got a huge boost from the fact that,
that Hitler was a national socialist.
And,
and that when he spoke about imperialism,
use the word nationalism and, um,
and um,
the,
the academic intellectual culture,
let's say it was still
still producing defense of,
of nationalism against imperialism
still through the 1950s.
But by the time you get to the
1960s, you get, um, Ellie Kaduri is,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, a famous
pro imperialists scholar who,
um, uh, wrote a book called nationalism,
which is kind of an anti
nationalist manifesto that, um,
blames nationalism for both World
Wars and a and says it's on,
it's unworkable for all
of the arguments that,
that are familiar to people
today are already in Kaduri.
He's a work that, uh, that
the divisions among peoples,
by creating independent states, you
create borders, borders are, are, are, uh,
always something people argue about.
That itself produces wars and triggers
wars and, and, and then the, uh,
the thinking that your country is great,
right,
and making your nation great again,
that kind of stuff that, it, uh,
the argument is that that kind
of nationalism necessarily
produces hatred and,
uh, hatred, violence, war intolerance.
It kind of takes all of the, you
know, the worst things of, of,
of recent centuries in the
past. And pins it on, on this,
this one word in this one idea.
So if that's not the case,
how did these ideas than pick up,
is this just sort of where we see this
now in academia where they just sort of
pick ideas that they sort of all agree
on are true and then it just runs
throughout,
uh,
the universities and then eventually
trickle down in the media and then get,
gets broadcast. The universities are, um,
are a hot house for the
development of ideas is, you know,
in principle is a really, really
wonderful to be good, right? In principle,
it's a really wonderful thing,
but, uh, but because, uh,
academia is overwhelmingly,
I mean, you know,
consists of, um, uh, uh,
a debate between kind of
Neo Marxists, uh, who,
who wanna you know, who, who,
whose aim is to achieve
justice by undermining pretty
much all inherited ideas
one after another. So there's
that. And then there's,
there's the great majority
of academics who are, uh,
who are liberals and,
and don't necessarily
agree with the neo Marxism,
but it turns out that they're not
very good at, uh, at, uh, at, at,
at resisting it. So academia
ends up being a, um,
um,
a fight between two universalist
visions and they're both utopian.
One is, is a neo Marxist Universal's
vision, which is utopian.
And the other is the liberal
universalists division,
which is Utopian and ideas
that are like nationalism.
Um, was there a particular artist
that are arguing for, uh, the, the,
the goodness of the justice of,
of defending your own people looking out
for their interests, their tradition,
their culture,
that kind of thing violates the
universalism of both the Marxists and the
liberals. Right. So have we watched
sort of the failure of liberalism here?
So if the Neo Marxists and the postmodern,
it's even if they're a smaller
percentage at the universities,
then the liberals that
the liberal somehow,
this is what I've been trying to noodle
through for the last couple of years ago,
that the liberals, somehow you
didn't have enough to stand on to,
to stop the bad ideas of the neo Marxist.
Yeah, exactly. You and you and you can,
you can actually see why because, because,
um, uh, the, the Neo Marxists have,
have a, I mean, the, the, the, the
agenda evolves and it develops, but,
but it's always, um, a, you know,
a very clear, uh, picking out,
picking out of ideas that need to be
destroyed and uprooted picking out of,
you know, institutions that need to
be destroyed and uprooted. They're,
they're constantly saying, to get
justice, then we need to overthrow this,
that, and the other thing. And the
liberals, they're responses. Uh, no.
Everybody just should be free
to do whatever they want.
And, you know, of course,
I'm very sympathetic to that, but,
but what you say, it's not enough.
It's not enough. When that's
the contest. One side is saying,
here's a really clear agenda for, for
what we gotta do in order to, to, to,
to fix the problems in the world.
And the,
the liberals are always some one
form or another of saying, well, no,
let's just everybody, like everybody
should do whatever they want and that,
that's not good enough.
If you,
if you're fighting a strong vision of,
you know,
what would be right,
you need an,
you need to counter it with
a strong vision or you lose.
And that's what happened.
I mean,
that's what I'm seeing right now with
the liberals in the United States.
It's like
this, this ever, uh,
dissipating group of people that are
sort of standing on quicksand because the
left, the neo Marxists have sort of taken
over the Democratic Party in all of the
apparatus of the left.
And then you have liberals who now mostly
secretly agree with conservatives in a
lot of ways, right? But they can't,
but they're afraid to say that.
And then there we're just watching
them whittle away. It's, it's,
it's sad to me in, in many ways for the,
for the ideas that I care most about.
Well, we don't know how it's going.
I don't, don't get too sad. You know,
we're really bad at predicting
what's gonna, what's gonna happen.
People are just bad at it. So, um,
we got to figure out what's worth fighting
for and we may win, we may lose. But,
you know, it's, um, um,
it's a mistake to think that we know
how it's all gonna turn out. We, we,
we just don't right now. Nobody, well, if
we knew I wouldn't be doing this, so I,
nobody predicted the, the, the,
the collapse of the Soviet Union or almost
nobody and nobody predicted the, the,
the, the rise of, of Brexit and
Trump and nationalism now where the,
that the housing bubble,
we're just, we're terrible at,
at seeing the future.
What we gotta do is we've,
we've got to think strategically about,
um,
what kinds of ideas that are out there
and what's needed and we need to work to
build up, um, uh,
an alternative framework that's going
to be more conservative and more
attractive and, and, and, and, and,
and capable of, of, of rallying people,
which, which I, I think liberalism is,
is less and less capable
of doing these days.
So, and I've seen you do some Twitter
threads on this sort of thought.
So I obviously want to talk about Trump
and Brexit and how they fit into this
conversation.
But, so if, if liberalism has
a certain, uh, fault here,
what are the answers that conservatism
has that you would say could stop some of
the rise of this new homework and stuff?
Conservatism,
the word conservatism refers to two
different political movements, which are,
which are traditional based,
their traditionalist. Um,
so conservatism is not,
it's not a universal theory,
so it's not like Marxism or liberalism
where you take a Marxist or a liberal and
they'll tell you, um, how the whole world
should think, you know, in all times.
In all ages, every place in the world.
Conservatism is not like that because,
because, uh, being a traditionalist
means, you know, I may,
I may respect more or less
the traditions of, uh,
of, of the Russians or the Chinese or
the, the, the Indians or the Germans,
but, but all those trades,
each, each one of them is
different, right? So, uh, so, uh,
some of them are like more in
some of them, like less in,
in the American context or let's
say the Anglo American context.
To be a conservative means a
specific thing. It means to be a,
to believe that the Anglo
American political traditions,
political and religious traditions are a,
uh,
an extraordinary achievement that
they, they are one of the, the, the,
the greatest, if not the greatest,
one of the greatest traditions, um,
that have ever been developed
in mankind's history.
And that most of,
um,
what we value in, in what we
love about the modern world, uh,
whether it's, uh, uh, the, the,
the idea of limited government
or a individual liberties or,
uh, or the, the, the, the kind of
science that that grows out of, uh,
uh,
out of Newton or the kind of culture
that grows out of a common sense,
skepticism. Um, all of these things there,
they're part of the Anglo American,
uh,
inheritance of a, an empiricist
attitude towards knowledge. Uh,
a common law tradition tradition, which
is not based on, on universal rights, but,
but which pioneered a freedom
of speech and freedom of, of,
uh, of, um, uh, of, uh, of property.
In fact, Mo, Mo, most of,
of what's in the American bill of
rights is these traditional English,
uh, English rights, which were
not developed by liberals.
They were developed by
conservatives fighting against, uh,
against the authoritarianism of,
uh, let's say the stewards. Um,
so when we talk about conservatism,
we're,
we're not talking about, um, there's, uh,
one set of ideas that are
eternally always true.
We're talking about a tradition of a
certain nation or a group of nations,
which by trial and error,
right? So it's empirical, right?
By trial and error over over centuries,
over thousands of years in fact,
have succeeded in,
uh,
developing and stumbling upon things that
are just spectacular and that are kind
of a gift to, to the rest of,
of mankind. And today what,
what we're seeing is that the,
the educational institutions,
rather than saying,
look,
let's take a look at the traditions of
this nation and, uh, and, uh, you know,
the thousands of years of development
going all the way back to the Bible,
let's see how it contributed
to, uh, the things that,
that we care about,
that that's what a conservative would do.
And say what contributed to,
to the things we care about and how
can we strengthen those strands in the
tradition, both nationally and also
in our, in, in our personal lives.
How can we live as conservative people
who will raise children to respect the
things that should be respected.
That's what conservatives focus on.
And so they're playing,
conservatives are always playing
a completely different game from,
from liberals.
Liberals are trying to try to tell you
some abstracts that have rules that if
everybody were to follow them,
then everything would be great.
And conservatives say there is no
such abstracts that have rules that if
everybody follows them, everything
would be great. What there is is um,
nations handing down a way of life
which have some good things about them,
some bad things about them,
but,
but everything that's good about them
is coming down from that tradition.
So we need to be working on
strengthening it and, and, and, and, uh,
and, and, and improving
it. So as we're watching,
what I would say is sort of the collapse
of liberalism on the left and now
there's sort of all of these refugees,
many of whom have been in this very
studio and who watched the show.
There are refugees that I think are
moving to something that is center right,
which I see is rich with ideas and
debate and all of these things.
I think a lot of people have some fear.
If you've come from the left,
they have some fear that there's some
sort of religious connotation attached to
conservatism. Now you just explained a
little bit of the history of that. Um,
but do you think there's room for
a secular conservatism? Can that,
can that fit within their look?
If it's a great question and there's no,
there's no simple answer
to it because, um, uh,
let me say one thing that's really simple.
You don't have to become a,
an Orthodox Christian or an Orthodox
Jew in order to take part in,
uh, in this great inheritance, which
is your inheritance. Okay. That's,
so,
it's a different question to say,
is it actually possible to sanitize it?
Of all religious aspects that,
that I'm, I'm more doubtful.
So let's take taken an example
that's really related to this book.
Um, uh, I, I mentioned
earlier that the, the, um,
the idea of national independence
is a biblical idea. Um,
the Romans didn't believe
in national independence.
The Greeks didn't believe in
national independence. I mean,
it has a source and that source is in,
uh,
in this tradition that says that,
you know, the god of Israel,
God, God, creator of Heaven
and earth is speaking to Moses.
And unlike all the other gods
of the ancient Middle East,
this particular God does not order his
people to go out and conquer the four
corners of the earth,
which is what the gods of the Assyrians
and the Babylonians were doing.
God event. That's a pretty big sea change
from what was happening before that.
It's an, it's an incredible, I mean that
in a, in at a certain level, that's what,
that's what the Hebrew Bible
is about. It's, it's about,
is there some alternative
to, uh, to living these,
these little tribes that are constantly,
we're each other or bringing peace
and prosperity by having, you know,
the Babylonians conquered
the entire world,
the four corners of the earth as they,
as they used to say. And uh, and so here,
the, the, the God of Israel speaks
to Moses and, and even though he's,
he's the creator of Heaven and earth, and
he's the god of everything. He doesn't,
he doesn't, he doesn't tell a
brand. He doesn't tell Moses, go,
go out and conquer the whole world.
He gives them borders the first,
as far as we know, the first borders,
any God ever gave his people, he says,
here are your borders and you're
not allowed to cross them.
You're not allowed to go trouble.
The neighbors because they have,
they have their own land and their own
promise and their own way. Now, this is,
this is a huge revolution
in political thought,
but,
but at the same time also also in theology
that that there could be a god that
cares about all humanity, but what
he wants is his, each different,
each different nation to, to,
to, to, to have its own freedom.
Now take that as an example.
That's,
that's something that I
think it's very difficult to,
to have an Anglo American conservatism
that uproots that biblical heritage.
Okay. Now that that doesn't
dictate, you know, what,
you know what you believe on every subject
just cause you're a conservative. But,
but if you don't have some kind of,
if you don't have a sense that there's
something incredibly important that needs
to be honored in hand handed
down in that tradition,
then it's going to be real hard
for you to be in conservative.
So how do you make room then? So I
get it. So on a, on a macro level,
you're saying you need though,
that those underpinnings on the micro
level for the individual that comes across
that maybe that either isn't religious or,
or for gay people or anyone that's,
that's sort of the outsider, uh,
how can they say, all right, well,
I can fit into this,
this conservative idea in different,
different times,
different periods of history.
Um,
uh,
there were tighter and looser,
mmm.
MMM.
More inclusive and less inclusive versions
of the traditions that we're talking
about. This is, I think there's,
uh, an important, common,
very common misconception about
conservatism is that often people are not
conservatives assumed that
the traditions are monolithic.
They dictate one answer on every question.
You know,
the tradition is this a
authoritarian thing? It,
it's always been the same. It has, you
know, it has a catechism and uh, and you,
you just have to believe and do
whatever you're told, and if you don't,
then then you're out.
I think that's a completely,
it's almost a propagandistic view of
the way traditions actually works.
The way traditions actually
work is that, that, of course,
a strong tradition. Um, does, um,
uh, does seek to inculcate
norms? When I say,
when I say norms, I mean, uh,
the thing that it would be best to do
where the thing that it would be best to
be,
but being the fact that the tradition,
hands down certain norms.
First of all,
there's huge arguments
within the tradition about
what those norms are, right?
I mean,
the,
the traditions themselves are very
often very pluralistic internally.
And then even if you're not
part of that pluralism, there's,
there's additional layers. There's the,
there's, there's the things that, uh,
that are,
uh,
strongly encouraged and the things they're
slightly encouraged and then there's
things that are tolerated. And then there,
then there are things, things that are,
uh, are, are, are
considered problematic, but,
but you'll leave them alone for now.
And then the things that the tradition,
you know, goes after and
tries to, uh, to say, look,
that that's really going to ruin us.
Right. Murdering people. It's a bit mind.
Right. So, um, so I,
I think that the more conservative
you become and the more you study what
conservatism really is as opposed to,
you know,
the cartoon version of it
that we get in, in, you know,
most academic courses on the
subject, let's say, or, or, or, or,
or on television, when,
when, when you study it,
of course you'll find things in
the past that you know, that, uh,
that you'll see as as terrible.
Nobody's pretending that's not the case.
But a tradition is something
that, uh, is always internal,
internally pluralistic.
Um,
it has different levels of space that it
makes for different, different kinds of,
of, uh, of dissidents and you know,
for, for, for example, the, the,
the English tradition is, um, it's,
it's often accused of being anti-catholic.
And,
and you'll notice that it's
relationship with, uh, with, uh,
with Judaism is not the same as its
relationship with Catholicism. Why?
Because, because the, the
periods that we're talking about,
our periods in which
Catholicism was, uh, uh,
was the official ideology of a world
empire that was trying to conquer,
conquer the English and prevent
them from being independent.
And I'm not saying everything
that was done in the name of,
of defending against this what,
you know,
w w w w w was perfectly well
executed, but you'll have to, I think,
use some common sense,
a nation that's facing a world empire
that has a certain religion that is,
that, that that's its
formal ideology. Well,
of course they're not going to treat
Catholics the same way that they're going
to treat other dissidents.
But I think people are always looking to,
looking at the past to see, um,
uh, oh, Gotcha. Look, they, uh,
the persecuted this and that and
the other thing and, and, and,
and usually it's true, but they're
not looking at the way in which,
um,
in which a dissidence did in
fact a flourish increasingly
over the millennia UN
under these, uh, these
different, um, uh, different,
different kinds of regimes. I mean, the
fact is we, Jews are still here. I mean,
has, there was plenty of persecution.
There's plenty to complain about.
But the fact is that we're still
here. And, and, and, and that,
that means that there were,
uh,
times in places throughout the history
of Christianity and Islam where,
uh, where the Jews had more or less
status, more or less tolerance,
more or less kind of contribution
in, in, in society. Um, and I,
so I, I would say that with
regard to conservatism today,
um,
we're in any case in a period where we're,
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to salvage what we can. All right. I mean,
I, I don't, I don't know if it's going
to succeed, but, um, as a conservative,
the maps that I face is today is virtually
every major idea or concept or ideal
that was handed down from the past
has been savagely attacked and may be
overthrown in the last few
generations. So I, I'm,
I'm talking about the idea of the nation
they did with the family. Uh, the,
the, uh, the,
the ideas of man and woman of God
and scripture of a holiness of,
of honor. I mean, you can just keep going
and going. I mean, anything that, that,
that I think created the things that
are good in our world today that really
worked is now being savaged
and, and destroyed. And I'm,
you know, I'm, I'm, I'm looking
for allies. I'm not looking,
looking for, for enemies.
I hear I have enough. I mean
the people who are, uh, and,
and, and it's, it's many
the ones who are actively,
purposely destroying these things and
the ones who were just going along with
them. I mean, that's most
of our culture. So, um,
you know, I, I, I would, I
would be real grateful for, uh,
a willingness to have conversation with
anybody who's willing to, uh, to try to,
uh,
to,
to work out a contemporary conservatism
that could do some good and that would
be as inclusive as possible.
All right then, so let's take this
conversation into the modern world.
There's a couple things happening
right now that sort of fit,
we'll let you talk about in the book,
but that,
that fit perfectly for this conversation.
So let's talk about Trump. First.
People described him as a nationalist.
He talks about America first,
as far as I can tell, he doesn't want
to nation build all over the world and,
and expand American
empire everywhere. Um, um,
that's sorta your kind of nationalism,
right? Yeah, it is. I, I, I,
I think on nationalism, Trump, Trump
is, is excellent. I mean, he's,
he's not just, um, he's not
just looking for ways, you know,
and this is,
you know,
whether you think that he's finding right
ways are proposing the right ways is
his, the, his theme is, is
looking for ways to try to, uh,
to think about America's
a nation rather as,
rather than as a world empire.
We need to come back to that in a second,
but with,
um,
but then he goes and he speaks in front
of the United Nations, right? And he says,
look, I'm not just saying, um,
that my job is America first.
I'm talking to all the nations.
I'm saying, look, each of you,
you're elected by a certain public or
you represent a certain public and,
and your job is to take care of
those people. And I think that's,
that's exactly the kind of, uh, of, of,
of nationalism we should be thinking.
Does that right there show you how
crazy things have gotten at the academic
level?
Because even when he says that,
that we should just think about ourselves
first that somehow is thought of as
Zena phobic or, or racist or something
like that. And it really, anyone,
if you really sat in it and thought
about it for a second or maybe if you,
if you remove Trump's
personality or whatever it is,
but have you thought about just what
he's saying that Americans should care
about America first and what happens with
our board first? It it sensible. I mean,
as you said at the beginning,
it's common sense of the people in the
United States are convinced that they
have some kind of a uniquely crazy
thing going on because of who Trump is.
I actually,
I think this is actually just not true.
I mean if you go just just go look at the
UK, right? They don't have Donald Trump.
You think that things are any less
crazy in the UK than they are?
And we'll get to exit in
a minute. But it's, Gee,
look at a sister democracy
within a lot of ways, a very, uh,
a very similar culture. And the, uh, the,
the elites I'm talking about
the universities, the media,
um, the, uh, um, a lot
of the, the, the, the,
the career politicians and bureaucrats,
there's this layer of people who are,
are,
they're just as crazy against,
uh,
any kind of indications of,
of nationalism and national independence
in the UK as, as they are in America.
So it's not, Trump didn't cause
this craziness. Trump is, is,
is actually more of an effect than he
is a cause. The craziness predates him.
The craziness begins with, I
mean, it has a long history,
but let's say roughly the craziness
begins roughly in 1989 when the,
um,
when the Soviet Union falls,
the Berlin Wall falls and
America, which had, had spent,
most of it's not, not
all, but most of it's, um,
uh,
two centuries of independence arguing
for the virtue of independent nations.
Right. Being mostly on that
side of things, right? When
the, when, when, when the,
when the,
the Americans were broadcasting their
radio broadcasts into Europe during World
War II, what were they, what were they
broadcast and they're broadcasting,
you've been conquered by the evil empire
and we're coming to free the nations of
Europe so that then they will be able
to live independently. That was like,
we're not coming to make
our little satellite, right?
Well, we're not coming to be,
you know, a better empire to
conquer you and rule you. Right? So,
so at the time it was clear
and I think most, most,
most probably don't realize how
incredibly unique that is, right?
That a country would go halfway across the
world to do that. Right? It's a, it's a,
it's a very special thing. You
know, and we can, we can talk about,
but this,
this goes back to your religion point.
When FDR on the eve of World War II,
right?
These FDR gives his, uh, uh, in,
in January of 1939,
he has a state of the Union address
where he can already see that America is
going to go to war against, uh, against
the fascists and maybe the communist too.
And, and, and he describes
what it is that we're,
what is it we Americans are fighting for?
What are we going to be fighting for?
And he says,
first of all,
for our religion and then from our
religion comes our democracy and our
willingness to have comedy among
nations. But he says, first and foremost,
religion effect.
He calls the allied nations,
he calls them the God fearing democracies,
right?
T today nobody would say their e t t no.
Nobody would understand that FDR and the
people then thought they were fighting
for God fearing countries
against atheist or totalitarians.
Nobody thinks like that anymore. But,
but, but that's what it was. All right,
so, so if we go back to, um, uh,
where does this willingness to allow
other nations, their freedom come from?
FDR At least knows that it comes,
that it comes from,
from Christianity that comes from Judaism.
And Christianity, but to go back to,
to, to uh, to the, the,
the current crisis.
We've got elites that, uh, after 1989,
and it doesn't matter if they call
themselves liberal or conservative.
I mean almost all of them,
Democrats, Republicans, Labor,
conservative in the UK and all,
almost all the parties in Europe went
after this utopian dream of one law to
cover the entire earth. Uh, uh,
George Hw Bush called it the new world
order. Like if you're a nationalist, you,
you hear this kind of thing, it just
sends a chill down your spine, right?
The Bells go off. Go off. What
that, that's why the American one,
the Cold War was to,
was to impose order on the entire planet.
And now America's going to decide,
I mean that,
that was really kind of a cookie
moment. And not only that, but,
but bushes that one world ordered order
speech. I mean he had a few of them, but,
but the particular one world order
speech and he says explicitly for a
generations, mankind has been
struggling to reach this moment.
It's like this utopian thing.
A thousand generations.
We've been struggling to
reach this moment, but, but,
but all the previous generations have
failed in. Now we're going to succeed.
What are we going to succeeded? He
says, we're going to eliminate the,
the law of the jungle and replace it by
the rule of law. Right. It, I mean it's,
it's like this, you know, John
Lennon, stuff like the, the, the, the,
the entire planet is going to be
this borderless thing under a single,
under a single law, somehow
automatically love each other and, right.
We all more with each other and we're
gonna have, because the whole comedy,
because the whole past was,
you know,
based on ignorance and darkness
and inclusion that, you know,
there was nothing good back there. And
I mean, he didn't explicitly say that,
but that,
that's the clear implication.
But it's funny that it's a very deal
Marxist idea coming out. H It's Georgia.
Absolutely. Absolutely. Nobody would
really think it absolutely is. But that's,
I mean, if you're, sometimes you
hear conservatives like me say it,
it's all just liberalism,
right? You know, it doesn't,
it doesn't matter what label they
put on it because, because the,
the fact is that,
that all the elites at the top of all
of these academic institutions and,
and, and, uh, political parties,
they had all these disagreements among
one another, but, right. They disagree.
They thought that they had
election campaigns, but they, but,
but they weren't disagreeing
about the fundamentals.
The fundamental was we
liberals in the west,
we know how to run the world. We've got
the answer. Like, all you need to do is,
you know, take, take the way
America runs and, or, or, or,
or Germany or whatever you want,
and uh,
and apply it to every country in the
world to every nation in the world.
But if necessary,
by force will dictate the rules.
There's going to rules
for the whole planet.
And if somebody does something wrong,
then we start bombing them. Which, I mean,
that's,
it's simplistic,
but that's roughly a description of
an entire generation of American and,
and, uh, and, and, and, and
European political thoughts.
It'd be like the neo conservatives
basically, right? Well, they're,
they're just one strand. I
mean, you'll, you'll, you'll,
you'll notice that the, the,
the, the neoconservatives, uh,
may may have been arguing
right for let's say invade,
invade Iraq and Afghanistan,
whereas Liberals in Europe
might've been saying, no,
don't invade Iraq and Afghanistan. So
there, there's substantive disagreements,
but what they're not disagreeing about
is that the European ideal of eliminate
all the borders, right?
A, uh, a, uh, the, the,
the, the European Union, uh,
founded in 1992 in, in, in,
in its current form, any right
after the Berlin Wall fell the idea,
we're going to take down all the borders.
We're not gonna have restrictions on
immigration or the free or, or, or, or,
or trade or, or, or, or
anything that we, every,
everybody's going to be free to be
part of one thing. And Europe itself,
you know, has no borders,
right? You're, you're, you're,
you're didn't know and still doesn't
know to this day how many countries on
earth it's going to expand to
embrace and its entire project.
The of the European elites is
creating a world's courts and,
uh,
and world economic bodies to regulate
everything on earth and get everybody on
one page doing, doing,
doing one thing. So,
so there's an argument between
the Europeans and the Americans.
Should the Americans be invading your act?
But there's no argument
about what the project is.
There's no argument about the idea that
we don't actually need diversity among
nations. We, we don't need
an independent nations.
We need one central thing that's
going to govern everything.
So is the simplest way to encapsulate
their argument is that's like the,
I get the d there's this dystopian idea
or sort of that by freeing everybody or
something that,
you know,
we'll just ignore thousands of years of
history and we're all going to love each
other, something like that.
But with the more, um,
the ferry version of this is that,
well,
one world government now you can
absolutely control everybody. I mean,
would you say that's really the heart
of this? It's really about control.
It's freeing everybody, right?
You're exactly right. It's, well,
they say they're freeing everybody.
But their idea of freedom is,
is, uh, you know,
let me take just a small example from,
you know,
from being an Orthodox Jew. I think
this applies to everybody, but, uh, but,
um,
uh,
they have an idea of what
human rights is and they,
they're sure that their idea of human
rights is true for everybody on earth.
Nevermind the fact that, you
know, every five or 10 years,
the content of it actually moves,
right? Right. But at any given moment,
right this way, but at any given moment,
they think that they know, you know what,
you know, what the absolute, you know,
what reason was a capital r what it
dictates is that the true setup for rights
for everybody on earth. So,
um, so as an Orthodox Jew,
um, I, I immediately run
into problems with this. Why?
Because, because, uh, we, we
have a tradition going back
thousands of years of, of,
uh, of Surrey circumcising our, our, our,
our male children. And, and it's, it's,
it's a, a, a central
symbol of, um, of, uh,
both the,
uh,
of the hardship of joining the
Jewish people and, uh, and,
and going into covenant with God.
That's our tradition.
You don't have to like it or not like it.
That's the way we do thing.
We can do things. It's incredibly
important to us now. Now the, the,
the universal reason people, they come
and say, well, look, you're biting,
violating the rights of the child. And
so you're not allowed to do that anymore.
We're, we're, we're, we're going
to ban it. Or, um, we have a, a,
a method of, of, uh,
slaughtering animals, uh,
four for food that goes back thousands of
years. Koch, kosher slaughter. And, uh,
from our traditional understanding,
this is a, this is humanitarian,
right? The, the, the, the, the
Jewish kosher slaughter. It,
it's aim is to eliminate,
among other things, to,
to eliminate things like, uh, uh,
hunting and tearing animals apart and
doing all sorts of other horrible things.
No, there's only certain animals you're
allowed to slaughter and you have to
slaughter to them in a certain way,
which,
which traditionally we thought that's the
most painless way. But now the, the uh,
the, the universal human
rights people are in this case,
the universal Vercel rights.
People that come and say, no,
you can't slaughter your away because
we know the answer of, of, you know,
of the best way to slaughter an animal.
And so you're going to do it our way.
I mean, basically what they're saying
is, is you're not allowed to be a Jew.
You're not allowed to be a traditional
Jew because we figured out the answers.
We figured out the answers for everybody.
And if you want to do it due to,
to do your traditions, then
that will shut you down. Now,
that same argument is true that I
just gave Forrest at ox Judaism.
It's true for everybody. It's
true for every tradition.
There is no such thing as,
as some professors in Germany sit and
figure out the universal human rights for
all time and,
and then we impose it on everybody without
oppressing all the other people have
their own traditions of how to do so.
Interesting to me because as you know,
I came from the left and I wasn't
progressive and I saw this and then when I
started waking up to it,
that's sort of when people started
caring about what I was thinking.
But I remember thinking that even when
the gay rights movement was happening in
America,
but there was this very odd thing that
if you didn't get to exactly where they
were on gay rights or
gay marriage that day,
they got there that you
were automatically a big,
and it's like what a crazy way of
viewing the world because Barack Obama,
who nobody in their right
mind would think is anti gay.
He ran against gay marriage.
She was not for gay marriage the first
time you went around. So history,
if these people win,
the long game history will be
not too kind to Barack Obama.
And I guess we're going to
have to take down his library,
which is being constructed right now.
I think they're gonna have to take that
down because he was against the human
rights that are going to be very obvious
to them that this is a 20, 30 years.
This is, this is such an
important point. I mean, the, the,
the only way that you can keep the,
the only way that you can preserve
mmm.
A certain way of doing things
or a certain idea is through
mmm.
Just through traditions that pass down
and attitude of sacredness and giving
honor to, to that way of
doing things. And you know,
of course nothing human is permanent.
Everything changes a little bit from
generation to generation. But, um,
but we see in, you know, by looking
at [inaudible], looking at the, the,
the Jews or in India or, or,
uh, or, or in China, we can see,
we see that are some things
that can actually be a
handed down over thousands of
years. It, it's possible,
but this idea that our reason is just
going to figure out the right thing and
nevermind the past.
That's just all that's doing is creating
a permanent revolution where every
single generation, I
mean, even every 10 years,
it already devours and reject and destroys
the thing that it created in just a
few moments ago. [inaudible] all right.
So there, there are some people who,
you know, who, who, um, who in theory,
they find that attractive. They,
I mean, they're, uh, the
young people usually,
right? Find that very attractive,
like everything before us
was awful. You know, it,
it's,
it's part of being apparently part of
being human is that a lot of adolescents,
um,
feel during their adolescence that really
nothing is important other than the
fact that I'm free and I decided to
do what I want. Um, and, uh, you know,
it's not true of all adolescents,
but it's true of a lot of adolescents.
It's a very, very common thing. And, and,
and, and it's part of being human. But,
um, but when, when you're a
grown up, um, you have to, uh,
take responsibility for questions like,
um,
is, is my nation, is my religion?
Are My traditions actually good?
If I believe that they're good,
if I believe they're
contributing good to the world,
then there are things I need to
do in order to hand them down.
It's not a few things. It's a
lot of things. Human beings,
if they're not, if, if,
if they don't work really
hard to uh, maintain the, the,
the honoring of the traditions,
the traditions get thrown out of the
window and you're going to have nothing
left. Now I'm like, let's
take something like, um,
free speech because I know you talk
about it a lot and free speech is people
think about free speech as though,
I mean it's the standard thing to say
is it's a right, it's a human right.
It's in the constitution,
it's a unit,
but people rarely way too rarely
focus on the fact that the actual
implementation of a regime of
free speech is a tradition.
It's a tradition.
If,
if you need to work hard to raise your
children to not tell the other one to
shut up,
but you need to train them over years,
it makes you angry that
your brother is saying that,
that your sister saying that.
Makes you angry. I mean,
th th they're constantly ready
to go to war over, right?
That's the way kids are and you have to
train them and work on them and work on
them to civilize them,
allows the other one to speak.
I know that it's making you angry, but
allow them to speak. Let them talk.
Then you'll get your turn.
Now that that little family Vignette,
it's actually true of the, of,
of the entire civilization.
The fact that that you can
have a, you know, a country,
most people are willing to allow someone
else to say what they think even though
they disagree.
That's an incredibly difficult
tradition to inculcate to,
to raise people to do that. That's a
fight that you have to refight in, in, in,
in the education of the entire
country and every generation it's you,
there's no point in asserting
it cause it's reasonable.
It's not about whether it's reasonable,
it's about what do,
what are you willing to do to make these
traditions channel people in such a way
that guess what, they're not free.
Someone says something you don't like,
then you're not free to just start,
start cursing them out
like people do on Twitter.
You're not free to do that
because self restraint,
self constraint is the only
way that freedom of speech
is going to exist in your
country.
That means that we need to focus on,
on the constraint part on how do you
get people to not do whatever they want.
That's the only way that free speech
can continue to exist. So the,
even even the things that seem to be
like the most valuable freedoms are,
they exist because they are
Anglo American traditions.
And if you're running a revolution where
you're overthrowing one tradition after
another, after another, nothing is going
to be left of the things that we value,
including the freedoms. So
all right, so that being said,
and that that could have
been the ending right there,
cause that's how your kappa show,
right?
But if everything you
said is true right there,
then how concerned are you for the future?
Because it does seem that the forces
that you're fighting against in this book
are getting stronger. Yeah,
it's it, it's very frightening.
It, Eh, on the free
speech thing, you know, a,
a generation ago I was
at university and, um, I,
uh, I started the, uh, the, the Princeton
Tory, it's the, it was the, the,
the pro Reagan publication on,
on the university campus.
And, um, of course, lots of people didn't
like it. Conservatives where I minority,
um, and people call me
names, people that, you know,
there's all sorts of nastiness,
but nobody ever thought it was
illegitimate. Right. It's a different era.
I mean,
w w we had friends who are liberals
and we'd friends who were progressive,
nobody thought that our
publication that are pro Reagan,
that are conservative publication,
that it was illegitimate. Right.
They didn't think, no, you're
not allowed to say that.
This is where someone like Ben Shapiro,
who often is just saying the things that
Reagan said that were brought over and
jet and tears. And today people
are, there's lots of things.
So in those days, I would just say
whatever I, you know, whatever,
I thought I would write whatever I
wanted. I, that's how I grew up. But I,
I tell my children, you know, and I'm
ashamed of this, but, but it's true.
I tell my children, no, look, there's
things you believe that you're,
you're not allowed to say anymore.
And I wish it weren't like that. I,
I'd like to see it change. But right now
there's no point in like in, in, you know,
throwing away your, your, uh, your,
your capacity to earn a living and to do
good on all sorts of fronts because you
insist in just saying whatever you want
to say. I can't stand it. But that's,
that's the reality is
that, is that the, uh, um,
the zone for,
for,
for freedom of speech is rapidly,
rapidly closing.
It's getting narrower and
narrower. And, um, and,
and that's just one example of the things
that we've lost. I think it's a very,
it's a very frightening period.
But let me just say one positive
thing because I mean, look,
I can easily plot a
trajectory where, um, where,
uh, where America doesn't
make it through this,
but w w w,
w w let me look at the other possibility.
This is also a moment of great
opportunity because it's,
there's a tradition among diplomats
that you read sometimes in,
um, in history books that kind
of a legend that the world,
uh, is like, uh, an ice cap. The political
world is like an ice cap and every,
every once in awhile it,
it unfreezes and it breaks
up and it rearranges itself.
So like every 50 years
or every 75 or 100 years.
And we really do seem to be
in a period like that where,
where all the bets really are off and,
um,
that will hopefully draw to the front,
um, creative, strong, uh,
people who have,
um,
well if something important to
offer to the rephrasing the re,
uh, re construction of, um,
of the world that's coming, um,
this reconstruction, you know, it,
it, it can be something
absolutely horrendous and I don't,
we shouldn't kid ourselves, we're really
moving in a bad direction. But, um,
the reason that I find,
uh,
the nationalist movements encouraging in,
in American the UK and other countries is
not because it's not because, you know,
I support everything that every
one of these people say or do.
I actually have absolutely no idea what
most of them, you know, are going to do.
And a lot of them are new to politics
and we don't actually know what they're
going to do, but, but what I, uh,
but I do see the opportunity. I D I don't
know if it's going to turn out well,
but I do see clearly the opportunity when,
um, when, right.
Because the national movements movements
could take a turn for the worst, right?
They could turn to things
that are about race.
They have no nationalism and those types
of things. They certainly could. And, and,
uh, and that is actually one
of the things that, that,
uh, that I say when I, when I
go around giving talks is I,
I've noticed that many conservatives,
um,
dismiss the, the racist,
right? I mean, they have a,
um, a lot of conservatives,
they look, they're looking at,
you know, how strong is the Nazi party
or the KKK and, and, and, and they are,
they're trivial. I mean, they're,
they're absolutely trivial
and it's completely unfair
to associate conservatism
with that answer. It's reasonable in
the sense that they dismiss it. But, uh,
but looking at the level of,
at the level of ideas of who's,
who's thinking,
who's trying to actually come up with
a worldview that could a few years from
now become some, something
important, I think it's a mistake to,
to dismiss the far right.
Not that I'm not that I'm
sympathetic to them, but the,
the quality of the, uh,
of the, the arguments,
the,
the work that's being done by people to
justify a kind of a neo Darwinian kind
of racism, like a white,
a white identity politics.
They're actually doing quite a bit of
work to get this idea into shape now.
I, I detest it, right? Aye.
Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye. Aye.
I hope it's soundly defeated,
but it's really quite a attractive to,
uh, lots of people in their twenties
and their thirties who are looking at,
you know, the, the old liberal
order and saying, oh my
gosh, well that doesn't work.
So, so where do we go?
Um, and it means that,
um, yeah, we have those of us who are, uh,
inclined to a national
conservatism that is, uh,
that has nothing to do with
race. That, that, you know,
those of us who think the color of your
skin really should make absolutely zero
difference in the way
that we order society.
There's so many important important
issues. Why the color of your skin.
So those of us who, who are, uh, um,
inclined to a national conservatism,
uh, which will, uh, believe in,
in the nation and its heritage, but I
have no interest in, in, you know, in,
in the genetic population that you know,
that you supposedly came from,
we have a lot of work to do to create
something that's going to be sufficiently
powerful.
I'm talking about an idea
that sufficiently coherent
and powerful and attractive
so that it will actually have,
uh,
be able to be politically effective
w before these other guys,
like the forces before these other guys,
you know,
before they win. I mean, right now they're
not winning, but 10 years from now,
20 years from, I would,
I think all bets are off.
We don't know where this is going.
And so, so there is there dangerous,
but there's an opportunity to create a,
uh,
a much more traditionalist,
conservative, um, uh, uh,
a decent, moderate common sense
traditionalist conservatism,
which will be national, which will
be nationalists, which we'll, we'll,
we'll believe in the
traditions of nations and, and,
and seek to maintain their independence.
There's a space to do that
and it's exciting to be
able to do that because that
space hasn't existed. You know, for
the last generation. It was, you know,
no one wanted to hear it.
It's,
that's a conservative space that
a good old fashion liberal could,
could be okay with. You know, we've
barely scratched the surface here,
but we got a rapper now, so we should,
we should definitely do this again. Okay.
I'd love to. Can I get you back here to
the United States and hear this again?
It in Israel. We'll do it intrusive.
I'll do either way. I'll buy,
I'll buy you a steak next to the old city
walls. If you come to Jerusalem, done.
I'm done. All right. For more on your arm
and follow him on Twitter. Why has one.